Doug Peterson back here in the Rich
Eisen show how are you coach rich I'm
doing well I just want to know where can
I go to vote how many times can I vote
you can vote you can stuff the ballot
box as much as you wish on the most the
most I guess the other trick play for
the Super Bowl here
yes you vote for the fridge right that's
it so I guess how is life bin I mean
what has it been like for you Doug over
the last couple of weeks ago you know
it's been a little crazy um things have
settled down some but but you know it's
just it's on fire right now
it's unbelievable here around
Philadelphia anywhere you go grocery
store post office out to eat dinner
whatever I mean it's just people are
still on fire and and for me it's it's
very special because of the the stories
that I hear you know about the this
generational here in Philadelphia being
our first soup win and you know that
guys have had people have had you know
to season tickets for for 40 50 60 years
and it's just amazing to hear those
stories and it's been you know for us as
a football staff to I mean that you know
there's change obviously so I've been in
the process of moving some guys and
shifting some guys around and trying to
hire guys and you know it's just a
little crazy that way but you know we're
back to normal now we're in the office
and we're getting ready for 2018 so
who's the first non family member you
heard from texts are called after you
want it all well I had 128 text messages
after the game my wife had about double
that she had more friends than I do
I you know Andy Reid was one of the
first ones I had on there as far as a
you know a non non family member a lot
of my you know close friends from from
back in Louisiana even even here in in
the pictures in Philadelphia area a lot
of my close friends here I was first
ones to to text and it was just it was
just excited was just really exciting
kind of surreal at the end of that game
and but I was able to get through all
those text messages and answering
everyone up yeah
and I'd love to just unpack the Andy
read of it all here because of what he
tried to do and st. came close to
attempting and pulling off in
Philadelphia is something that you were
able to do what was that moment like
when he was able to share a Philadelphia
championship that you were able to bring
and and you were being part of those
years attempting to bring with Andy Reid
how did he how did he take it you know
he was he was classy
class act very complimentary and and and
really you know I said this
after the game and he was couple days
after the game I talked about you know a
lot of these players that we have on
this roster are were drafted by Andy
Reid
you know the Fletcher Cox is Brandon
Graham's Feeny Curry's Nick Foles just
to just name a few and so a lot of a lot
of the guys that were on the field that
day were a direct influence on coach
reading and what he what he brought to
Philadelphia and he was just excited
he's excited I was me personally but at
the same time excited and thrilled for
the city of Philadelphia Doug Peterson
champion head coach here on the Rich
Eisen show so Nick Foles when he took
over the controls at the end of the
regular season looked nothing like the
Nick Foles
that we saw in January and obviously in
early February were you holding anything
back I mean what walked me through this
transformation as it seemed to just yeah
outside eyes coach well you know and a
lot of the outside eyes couldn't see and
didn't see Nick prepared in a week and
and what people tend to forget is is he
missed a lot of training camp time with
with these starters with some of the
guys that he would you know that he
would have played with in the Superbowl
he missed the regular season reps with
these guys because Carson Wentz was was
was playing and starting and and so it
just it takes time it's not you just
don't flip the switch and go okay he
played you know he started a couple
years ago he was 27 and two touchdown
interception ratio you the pro boy it
just doesn't happen it just doesn't flip
the switch it takes some time
so what you have to realize that he was
sort of back in training camp mode we're
trying to knock the dust off and the
rust off of Nick Foles and basically get
the offense back to some of the things
that he was comfortable with and what he
liked and you know having conversations
with Nick and and just sort of a feel
out process to get to where we were
going into the postseason and and yeah
it didn't look pretty at the end of the
year and you know rightfully so but
that's that's what we put out with what
we put out on the field so I can I can
understand that part of it but we had a
bye week going into the postseason which
we got back to a lot of the basics a lot
of the fundamentals with him and and the
team offensively focused in on the run
game some of the things it was you know
some of his strengths as a quarterback
and and then and then we've sort of you
know the second half at the Atlanta game
we kind of came alive as an offense shot
the ball down the field a couple times
and found a way to win that game and
then the Minnesota game against a great
great defense great great team to come
out and play the way we did and the way
Nick did was was tremendous but it's all
sort of everything was accumulating now
reps were accumulating time time at the
quarterback position was accumulating
reps with Zach Ertz and Alshon were
accumulating and just getting it on the
same page and then the the 38 to 7 win
over Minnesota was was exciting and and
then we had another bye week so we could
prepare again and just keep accumulating
reps and you know Nick's not a not a
rookie he's a veteran guy he's he
started several games in the NFL and it
just began to show his confidence the
deeper we got and the more the more
opportunities he had and then of course
coach the confidence level to any time
out in the Superbowl prior to the first
half to come up and suggest the trick
play that that we were talking about
earlier the Philly special and now a
couple of things about that moment why
why the timeout I thought when you call
that timeout that you just
to settle for a field goal at that point
in time was that part of the process at
all no it was not a part of my sin my
thought process at all the time is at
the time on the clock was actually
running out of it and we got out of the
huddle late and so I didn't want to
waste I didn't want to waste a play or
try to hurry up a play and and and not
execute it properly and and and so just
burnt I burned the time that we had
timeouts in that situation so I wanted
to burn the timeout I again I just I
just keep remembering you're playing Tom
Brady you're playing Bill Belichick it's
New England Patriots they've been in
this spotlight before and we have to
score touchdowns it's it's I said after
the first series of the game to the
offensive staff we can't kick field
goals and win this game we can't do it
and and so I had made my mind up at that
time that I was going to go for it and
and is you know fortunate we got the
timeout and then Nick ran over and we
were looking at a couple of plays a
couple of +5 red zone plays some
two-point plays in that situation and
you know he whispered Philly special and
I just looked at him and we locked eyes
and I said let's go I love that part
coach you know we saw that in the NFL
Films coverage that you'd locked eyes
what was that to second thought process
for you before you said let's do it was
like it was like that it that lets go
that's the confidence we needed that's
the confidence I love seeing from you
know from the players I was like could I
see that that play was actually part of
our +5 red zone and I had actually
marked it down as like a maybe a plus
three plus two you know in the red zone
area low low red zone area you know we
were down in there really tight and it
was like it's the it is the purchase the
perfect call at the right time of the
game and and our guys our guys didn't
bat an eye they executed is extremely
well the play we had in actually for
about three weeks we wrapped it against
the Vikings during that week we didn't
call it obviously carried it over into
the Superbowl game plan and and guys
guys pulled it off and it was a is it
you know a big part of the
in the Super Bowl so the Philly special
was not the play that you would have run
had the clock not run down at the time
out was it was not it was not it was not
I had a different they called at the
time what was that that we had that I
had called and I honestly cannot
remember the half crossfire look at my
call see to see what I had and pull out
the clout the notes from the game but it
was not to call at the time that I that
I called the timeout no by the way if
you just just don't for the rest of your
life don't even remember it it's a much
better story
I don't and a couple more minutes left
here with Doug Peterson of the champion
Philadelphia Eagles here on the Rich
Eisen show what's with the ice cream we
noticed that also that you would always
break I guess what the Saturday night
meeting before the night before game
always all for ice cream the players
already say there's ice cream in the
back I mean what's we all you know we
have a team snack after the team beating
you know Saturday night at the hotel and
there's always there's always desserts
and paying just try the one time of the
week did you know that our players get
to kind of eat junk food a little bit
you know and and indulge in there and
there's some of their cravings and I
always have ice cream and you know we
have pies and cookies and things like a
desserts and stuff and and so I just I
just started coining coining the phrase
just you know hey I've got some we got
it we got a highlight video to watch and
after where I got some ice cream it's
kind of melting it in the cafeteria over
here we got to get to it so so let's
watch this video and got some ice cream
you know melting let's get ready when
you're ready and watch it so is it
something that kind of caught on
throughout the year obviously our our
video guys you know they record those
those meeting and they put out that
little spoof of me I don't know ten
twelve clips I guess of me saying that
and it kind of caught fire I do love ice
cream is probably my favorite dessert
and vanilla is my favorite flavor and
that's what we have okay
it's odd that somebody who calls whose
play sheet is so exotic you just go
straight vanilla coach I'll be very
honest no I know that
no toppings no no straining no well you
know I put a little strawberry topping
with some whipped cream cheese a little
special to that so as we are sitting
here obviously we were months from
training camp
what is the plan with whence do you plan
on having a back week one coach you know
we're optimistic obviously I don't want
to put a timetable on him
obviously he's working extremely hard
he's in the weight room he's giving us
rehab done you know he's he's working
good but at the same time I'm not gonna
rush him you know what we did with
Sydney Jones I didn't want to you know I
didn't want to put him out there if he's
not if he's not a hundred percent so
optimistic you know that that could that
could come come to fruition but again
we'll be smart about it and and you know
we'll put them out there when he's ready
and it's amazing how things happen you
go from one week you're the MVP of the
league in five weeks later because the
backup wins at your system quarterback I
mean it's it's it's it's nuts I think
but what wordy
where are you what do you tell people
who say that about Carson Wentz because
of what Nick Foles was able to do coach
listen Carson Wentz was the MVP talk you
know of the league last year and I truly
believe if he's you know if he's healthy
and I still feel strongly that we're
probably in the Superbowl and win the
Super Bowl with Carson to some you know
and he's the MVP I mean I just think
it's that's just the way he's that's
just the way he played last year and he
he's a big reason he's not the only
reason but he's a big reason why we were
I believe 11 and 2 at the time you know
playing the Rams and and won the NFC
Eastern and you know it's it's for me
being a former quarterback to have two
guys that really three guys you mean
feel made in there but you're talking
about making Carson who you just don't
bat an eye with either one of these guys
the way they prepare the way they study
their their their demeanor on the field
their leadership styles I mean it's just
uh it's a blessing you have two veteran
guys like that and now have have an MVP
a Super Bowl MVP as your as your backer
Andy's might grow the replacement for
Frank Reich might grow hmm
for Frank yes might grow yeah yeah Mike
is uh
the replacement for Frank feel
comfortable with helmet and I've got
listen I've got I've got a great
offensive staff and this is a I've said
this before and and it's a collaborative
effort even when Frank was coordinator I
was a collaborative effort
you know John D flipbook was a big part
of what we did do staleys a big part
just Alan so get guys that that we put
game plans together and and not one guy
not one guy it's uh you know gets the
credit but Mike is been promoted and I'm
excited to do hey coach congratulations
I mean as you pointed out at the
beginning of this conversation the
number of generations that you made
thrilled and gave memories to based on
how you you conducted yourself and work
the roster and got everybody ready and
kept him kept him all salty and with dog
masks and all that sort of stuff and
with Lane Johnson and and and the guys
having fun ice cream and celebrations
and whatever it it was a lot of fun to
watch and I'm thrilled for you
so congratulations well rich thank you
yeah I really appreciate it guys it's a
great group to work with and it it and
uh you know we're just the hardest thing
now is trying to big-big our backs now
going forward but I wouldn't want it any
other way
alright thank you so much no coach I'll
see an Indy Congrats all right you bet
that's Doug Peters the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience